think about how you learned at least I
hope you learned how to tie your
shoelaces how did you learn to tie your
shoelaces and the short answer is you
did not spend like some two-week
intensive where all you did was tie
shoelaces all day every day and they're
like no I know how to tie shoelaces you
just tied your shoelaces like once a day
or if you're more like me like once a
week over a long period of time and then
that process as complicated as it is
it's quite complicated and you'll know
that if you ever teach someone how to
try and tie a knot that complicated
process got into your brain you can do
it without even thinking you could
probably do it without even looking at
your shoes right now right we're going
to do the same with this and I encourage
you to do it regularly to have that over
time just touch back on the come back to
them over and over again rather than try
and do it in a tentative way this
morning we introduced this idea and some
of these are easy because we did them on
the circle other ones will take a little
bit more work what was the very first
one we had a look at a taxi at the
bottom when you looked at a full
revolution right 360 degrees we said on
a unit circle if you had a 360 degree
angle how far would you go around the
circumference to make that on the unit
circle how far would you go all the way
around which in the unit circle what
length is that is two pi and so that's
what we call the Radian measure for that
angles 360 degrees it's two pi I think
the next one we did was half of that
what's in it so a hundred eighty degrees
in radians that will be PI radians and
then we went I think we have to get
didn't we so we got up to 90 degrees
so if I have again I'm going to get PI
on two now those are the ones which was
sort of known but you don't have noticed
I've actually got a much longer list
because these are pretty much the ones
which yes you will definitely have to
have memorized because they come up so
frequently just like you saw before in
regular trig with degrees so let's now
that we've got the ones we know let's
just go from the top you can see by the
way I've got these which are lots of 45
in a different color this is also a lot
of 45 and also a lot of 30 so that's why
it's in blue but I've indented it and
these are the most common ones you're
going to get which are bigger than 180
okay that there are others you'll see as
well let's go for the top zero degrees
how many radians is a big bat going to
zero good it's not like Fahrenheit and
Celsius which have different zeros those
are super confusing when we go to 30
degrees I think the easiest way to think
about it is 30 degrees is a sixth of a
hundred and eighty degrees
it's a sixth so therefore if this is PI
then to get from 180 degrees to 30
divided by 6 so this should be PI on 6
PI on 6 all right we already did 45
degrees was one of the examples it's PI
odd four very good now when you're from
30 to 60 you're doubling aren't you so
instead of pilot six you'll get PI on
three very good that's to pilot six
isn't it there's PI on three and
hopefully you're noticing because that's
the way fractions work right the
denominator is getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller right
six four three two we get to 120 degrees
which is the easiest how do you express
this in terms what we've already got
yeah very good take that of 2.3 nailed
it because it's double the 60 that you
already see there okay 135 oh this is
double this so I doubled 60 to 120 pi of
3 to 2 pi 3 yep 135 3.4 cuz it's 3 lots
of 45 degrees 3 PI on 4 say again that's
right it's it's this one ha no you to me
135 degrees
yes it's gonna be 3 point 4 because it's
how many lots of this have I got it's
three of these and that was planned for
okay I'm doing all of the lots of 30 and
all of the lots of 45 all the way up to
180 so my last stop here 150 degrees
have a look there the difference c18150
is 30 right so it's one of these take
away one it's gonna be five pilots six
or if you like five lots of that both of
the same five PI on six and there my
last one that I've got in this sort of
canonical this 270 degrees have a look
on the list what would you say that's in
terms of 70 it's three lots of 90 right
three lots of 90 we already established
that 90
that so it's three of these three
point-two yeah so basically not to lead
to much into lunchtime as you're in
radians you're just going to think of
everything in terms of pies everything
in terms of pies if this is a straight
angle right if you want something less
than a straight angle you're gonna have
less than a pie if you've got something
more than a straight angle you're gonna
have more than a pie right so three
point two that's gonna be a hot on my
fingers my until I go around the right
way a reflex angle right three PI on to
270 degrees all right now you might
recall unreal learning exactly is the
first time we drew a pair of triangles
the ones on your reference chain now the
ones on the reference tree are in
degrees but we're trying to get
ourselves into a new road so let's start
with this guy here this exact right
angle triangle you might recall it's got
a 1 and a 2 on the hypotenuse they don't
remember what the other like this
it's a surd you go very good through
three now we called this what are the
angles of this one we're usually called
for 30-60-90 triangle 30-60-90 which
angle would normally be 30 degrees so
one on the top you can see that's why
I've drawn it nice and thin but we don't
wanna write 30 degrees we want to write
pile of six right so I'm gonna pop plan
six up there alright so this is 30
degrees piled 6 radians if this one is
60 degrees it should be on three very
good now you've already got the right
angle they're telling you it's size but
just for completeness let's write this
in radians right 90 degrees right angle
it's gonna be PI on to and of course
because you know what the angles of a
triangle is right PI on 6 plus PI on 3
plus PI on to how many radians will that
bit and we PI it because that's the 180
degrees right all right so that's that
guy you've also got this other triangle
the isosceles one so if you make those
both one then our hypotenuse is gonna be
it's the it's the certain again right so
this is the square root of 2 that's what
I meant to say yep good
you've got your planter here which we
already just looked at and then these
two angles are usually what usually in
degrees
45 degrees so we've already established
that instead of 45 we should write we
should write plan for thank you very
much paid for here pile for also here
all right one last thing when we were
this is where we're leading right well
we were solving trigonometric equations
in the past you may recall we used this
our quadrants diagram do you remember
that and then we would say all stations
to central just ringing a bell right
some of you are less familiar with this
because it was looked at in 5-3 but
hopefully we can remind you of it well
we use this we would say oh this is
acute angles not 290 right but I'm not
going to say not to 90 degrees anymore
I'm gonna say naught to not 80 degrees
PI on to right so I'm gonna say in this
quadrant I'm gonna write 0 is less than
let's call it theta could call it X
doesn't matter is less than PI on to
that's the range of angles you can have
in there from naught to PI on 2 radians
when you go over here into obtuse angles
right I have to say angles in degrees we
would say that's between 90 and 180 but
I'm not gonna say that because I'm in
radians instead we're gonna say PI on 2
all the way up to PI very good and I can
continue can you finish off the rest of
the diagram have your third quadrant
down here so 270 degrees is have a look
three point two so I go from PI all the
way up to 3 PI 2 and then my last one
down here 3 PI and 2 all the way up to 2
pi that's the end okay now something
that is worth adding into this it's why
I've left or this space in the middle of
these quadrants is when you work out the
solutions in each of these right for an
acute angle you'd say well it's just
whatever that angle is and when you work
out its equivalent over here you used to
say 180 degrees - whatever that base
angle was but I'm not gonna say that
anymore instead of 180 degrees minus
theta I'm gonna say
where's 180 degrees there it is
I'm going to say pi-minus-theta
right when you're coming up with a
solution for trigonometric region which
we're about to do shortly here it's not
pi minus theta it's PI plus theta you're
getting bigger
pi plus theta and then the last one we
usually would say 360 degrees take away
your base angle but I'm not going to say
360 I'm gonna say 2pi take away then egg
okay